you are having a coffee with a close
friend and bring up how you need a new
bathing suit then BAM all of a sudden
there are ads on your phone for bathing
suits our smartphones are with us at all
times but our companies and governments
using them to spy on us you may be
suspicious for a good reason a New York
Times piece uncovered that thousands of
apps including gaming apps for kids are
equipped with the software Alfonso
Alfonso uses your smartphone microphone
to listen to the ads that you are
watching on TV it uses audio signals to
collect TV viewing data in order for
advertisers to personally promote things
to you online
Alfonso claims to not record human
speech Facebook has created a device
called pixel which is designed as a way
to continue tracking you online even
after you've left a website by dropping
a small piece of data called a cookie
your device will now remember
information like how long you linger on
a certain item and whether you added
anything to your shopping cart but
didn't purchase it millions of websites
use Facebook pixel which is why the hot
you didn't end up buying follows you
around Facebook forever but sites like
Facebook even follow you offline and
have been known to purchase information
and create a database of over 52,000
different attributes about you for
example Facebook buys data from
supermarket loyalty programs so if you
have a points card with a grocery store
Facebook may be paying to understand
your purchasing patterns potentially
learning about what you eat or even what
type of toothpaste you use so your phone
can listen to you but it can also follow
you as well every time you receive a
text or use data to load an app
companies can log and retain your
location based on the cell tower and
cellular antenna you connect it to the
precision of location has increased over
time and get paid a detailed picture of
where you go so your phone may start
sending you ads for swimsuits because
you were just physically in or near a
surf shop these companies will claim
they aren't doing anything you haven't
agreed to as you have accepted the
privacy policy that allows the
collection of your information and did
you read the fine print
probably not a study presented 543
participants with a fake app called
named
to see how many would read the privacy
policy and Terms of Service 74% skipped
reading the agreement all together and
those who did read it didn't do a great
job ninety-eight percent of participants
missed the gotcha clauses which included
sharing all your data with the NSA your
employer and agreeing to provide your
firstborn child as payment and what
about the rise of smart speakers like
Google home in Amazon Alexa which are
designed to listen to you at all times
though they are supposed to only record
your voice when giving prompts like ok
Google recently a couple found that
Amazon's Alexa recorded a private
conversation and then randomly sent it
to a friend
these are deemed unfortunate glitches
but what if someone gained access to
them as Wi-Fi networks and mobile
internet devices are easier to hack than
you might think your typical wireless
internet information is kept
confidential by being converted from a
readable state to nonsense at the access
point and then converted back to a
readable state when you use the correct
Wi-Fi password from your computer when
internet moved from physically wired
networks to wireless technology it
became easier to hack and less secure
because the encryption schemes are
relatively simple for example your
webcam can be hacked by creating a
remote access tool which is the digital
equivalent of someone adding an unlocked
window to your home without you even
noticing also the FBI agent meme isn't
far from the truth as the FBI is known
to use phishing which is slipping a link
into a message that is labeled in a
misleading way when you hit the link
your device connects to the FBI's
computer downloading malware which is
then able to covertly spy on long story
short your phone is capable of listening
to you following you and even watching
you if online security and privacy is
important to you make sure you check out
today's sponsor of our video nor to BBN
who is offering you 77% off of a
three-year plan if you use the promo
code a sub science or go to Nord VPN
comm slash ASAP science VPNs or virtual
private networks
encrypt your Internet traffic and mask
your identity online so people can't see
where you're searching or get access to
your private information Nord VPN is the
world's most advanced VPN service using
military-grade encryption they also
offer a super-fast experience with
almost no impact on speed while using it
and s features like an automatic kill
switch browser proxy extension ad
blocking and many more Nord VPN even
bypasses the Great Firewall of China and
works in the Middle East where not all
VPNs work with 4300 servers and Counting
in 62 countries they're constantly
growing expanding which separates them
from other providers on top of all this
you can use it on six devices
simultaneously like your phone your
computer your tablet so that you're
protecting your information at all times
including if you're on public Wi-Fi
again you can use the promo code ASAP
science or head to Nord VPN comm slash
ASAP science to get 77 percent off of a
three-year plan and start protecting
your privacy online thanks so much for
watching and we'll see you next Thursday
for a new science video